c'est que ce bonjour alors armin laschet
membres de la cedeao qui a toujours un
soutenir angela merkel a clairement pris
ses distances comment expliquez-vous ce
revirement de situation dont il faut pas
parler de revirement de situation à mais
la chute est l'un des prétendants à la
succession d'angela merkel le problème
c'est que à l'intérieur du gouvernement
allemand mais notamment l'intérieur de
la syrie où il n'y a pas de position
totalement clair concernant l'avenir de
l'europe et surtout quelle réponse
donner aux propositions qui date de 2017
le sou le souligner à emmanuel ray mc
roi très simplement il y à du côté
allemand d un type eu des hésitations
concernant la politique européenne et
qui sont aussi liées à la question de la
succession de la chancelière et aux
problèmes internes actuelle que traverse
l'allemagne d'édition des problèmes il
est question de fond il a critiqué le
manque de réactivité de la chancelière
par rapport à la politique des macros la
politique européenne est ce que on peut
imaginer de bonnes relations entre les
deux hommes si jamais armin laschet
devient on devient chancelier la presse
d'un gala merkel alors que arminda fils
devienne chancelier s'il me disait sur
un cheval qui n'est peut-être pas le
meilleur des chevaux actuellement c'est
frais des chimères pied qu'une de alors
comme beaucoup plus la droite
tanguay a marqué youtube et carmela
celle qui a les plus grandes chances de
prendre la succession mais attention là
aussi il faut faire preuve de retenue
aujourd'hui la question de fond qui se
posent même quelle coalition
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on va avoir une
coalition à l'autrichienne s'était
ouvert avec friedrich ebert qui est un
néolibéral un conservateur très marqué à
droite avec des verts allemands qui ont
certes beaucoup moins gauche à gauche
que d'autres verts mais qui si on reste
quand même plutôt un parti de centre
gauche
rien n'est moins sûr la question
fondamentale aujourd'hui en allemagne je
suis l'un des rares à le dire
c'est tout simplement qu' il y a une
fiche politique qui se profile car ne
sais pas du tout à quoi va ressembler
collectivement l'allemagne d'ici
quelques mois ou au plus tard d'ici un
an et demi c'est à dire la date
programmée jeudi par daniela merkel de
la chancellerie
vous venez d'évoquer fredrich merde qui
est le concurrent de lâcher on vous
l'avez dit vous-même il est très à
droite il cherche même à récupérer une
partie des électeurs qui seraient tentés
par l'extrême droite
que se passerait-il si jamais il était
élu est-ce que cela marquerait un
tournant pour pour l'allemagne ans alors
je les téléspectateurs français ne sont
pas au courant de ce qui se passe chez
williams en elle même qui derniers jours
mais ce qui s'est passé en curage avec
l'élection la non élection d'un ministre
président soutenu ipso facto par tous
les partis plus à droite que les verts
et que les expédie que la ligue 1 c'est
un coup de semonce c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui et je me répète on ne
sait pas du tout quelle type de
coalition peuvent aujourd'hui émergé en
allemagne et si friedrich merz qui a les
faveurs des pronostics a des chances
d'être le candidat d'accéder ou de ces
soupes aux les prochaines élections
rien de vie aujourd'hui et cela peut
paraître curieux qu'il soit en position
d'être
lancelier on ne connaît pas du tout quel
va être le score de la cdu ou par
rapport aux verts ou par rapport à spd
et surtout à l'intérieur de la td ou
dessous il y à de très très grande
différence du stratifié les uns
penseraient ils sont encore minoritaires
vers une alliance avec l'extrême-droite
de la mdd autres disent non ça ne rentre
pas en ligne de compte
et il ya quelqu'un qui est très clair là
dessus c'est le ministre président de la
bavière marque the hunter qui encore
hier a clairement dit qu en aucun cas il
y est il y aura une possibilité
d'alliance quelle qu'elle soit entre la
vidéo et l'afd et qui sont épris
directement avait su mettre 110 en plus
de voir ou pour les bavarois d'accession
qui sont de tradition plus conservateurs
mais qui aujourd'hui semble connaître
aussi un processus politique interne
assez intéressant que donc pour les
conservateurs bavarois de l'atce où il
n'ya pas de favoritisme envers frédéric
maire sylviane au contraire merci en
tout cas monsieur gilbert casas sus
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation et
nous éclaire sur l'allemagne je rappelle
que vous êtes professeur en études
européennes